several teenagers take some pills that
are supposed to make them more sociable
and intelligent but they realize that
there is a sinister conspiracy behind
that medicine
today on cinema recap i'll show you
the privilege
the movie begins with a boy named finn
home alone with his sister at night when
suddenly they both see a monster into
their house so they decide to go out and
try and flee in a car the monster
catches up with them and stops the car
so they decide to leave on foot the
sister tells finn that they have to jump
over a bridge
finn doesn't want to so he pushes his
sister making her fall alone
after a while the police arrive and find
the body of finn's sister and he's so
traumatized by what happens that he
ceases speaking several years later finn
has become a teenager and he's going to
therapy
in one session the doctor tells him the
monster he supposedly saw was only a
product of his imagination
and also gives him some pills so he can
better socialize
later finn goes to school with his other
sister a twin named sophie
finn leaves sophie with her boyfriend
and then goes to meet his friend named
lina at night finn goes to a party but
he just stands there watching the others
dance
when suddenly a young man appears and
gives him a liquid telling him that if
he drinks it he'll be able to relax
finn decides to drink it since he wants
to be confident enough to go talk to the
girl he likes
however when he drinks it he gets dizzy
and begins to hallucinate
seeing all of them covered in blood the
next day finn wakes up with a headache
but he only drinks a smoothie
then he goes to see his grandfather at
the hospital and there sees an old lady
on a stretcher but he just ignores her
later finn returns home where he
overhears his parents talking saying
that finn is not ready for something yet
at night he goes to sleep but in the
middle of the night he hears some noises
in his house so he gets up to look
around
then finn sees his parents in the living
room taking off his twin sister's
clothes
at that moment he sees the old lady saw
in the hospital who approaches his
sister and touches her body suddenly the
monster appears and pushes finn causing
him to pass out
in the morning finn wakes up and his
parents tell him that he sleepwalked
during the night and fell down the next
day finn is getting ready to go to
school when suddenly he sees the monster
attacking sophie in the closet so he
goes to help her but when he opens the
door he realizes that she is fine
that what he saw wasn't real
later finn goes to school and tells his
friend lina what he saw and tells her
that he's afraid that something will
happen to sophie since she has just
turned 18 and she's the same age as his
other sister when she passed away
that day at school sophie's nose
suddenly bleeds and she gets very sick
so they send her home to rest there her
boyfriend comes to visit but she rejects
him and tells him that she never wants
to see him again
finn thinks that's weird since his
sister had never behaved like that
before that night finn is taking care of
his sister while she sleeps and we see a
creature hidden under her bed
at that moment finn receives a message
from his sister's boyfriend named rameen
ramin tells finn that he has something
important to tell him and that both he
and his sister are in danger so they
agree to meet at a coffee shop then we
see that ramin is waiting in the
cafeteria when he suddenly hears some
strange noises so he looks around and
finds a lady lying on the floor
remain approaches the lady to help her
and at that moment the lady opens her
eyes it makes rameen fly several beaters
back then rameen gets up a bit dizzy
and the lady ties a cable around his
neck and begins to hang him after a few
minutes finn arrives at the cafeteria
and starts looking for rameen but he
finds him dead the police arrive and
tell him that rameen took his own life
to which he replies that it's impossible
since ramin had something important to
tell him but the police don't listen
finn and his dad go home and tell sophie
that her boyfriend died
later finn goes to his room and as he
was going to take the medicine the
doctor prescribed he realizes that
there's a worm inside one of the pills
the next day finn takes the worm to
school it seems to be getting bigger and
bigger and he asks one of his teachers
what kind of worm it is the teacher
tells him that it's a very rare fungus
that it normally grows on corpses
then finn and his friend lena start
researching this fungus on the internet
and discover that it is a fungus that
causes hallucinations
and that in ancient times they were used
by witches and shamans because they
believed it was a door to the world of
demons
later finn and lena decide to go see a
woman who's an expert on mushrooms and
tell her about the fungus they found in
the pill
the lady immediately gets concerned and
has finn if he has seen a monster when
vin says yes the lady asks him to look
her in the eyes
and makes him expel the pills he had
taken earlier
finn tells her that his sister also
takes the same pills and that she's not
feeling very well the lady says she has
to perform an exorcism on his sister
because if she doesn't the monster will
go for her however finn doesn't believe
her and decides to leave then he goes to
see his grandfather at the hospital and
since he used to be a priest finn
decides to ask him if he ever saw any
kind of demon the grandfather tells him
that he saw one in the past when he
performed an exorcism on a child
saving him from the demon
so finn starts thinking that maybe he
should call the lady to help his sister
as well
finn goes home and his parents tell him
that they're going to the hospital when
they leave finn calls later to perform
the exorcism on his sister and minutes
later lena and finn's crush named samira
also arrive
the lady and her son arrive and they
install all their devices to communicate
with the beyond then everyone sits the
table and the lady begins to ask if
there is a spirit in the house
after asking several times the monster
appears and attacks the lady at that
moment finn's parents arrive and when
they turn on the lights the monster
leaves
finn's parents asked the lady to leave
so she and her son do so finn's parents
ask him for an explanation but finn
decides to run away from home with lena
and samira finn lena and samira leave in
a car and look for a place to spend the
night meanwhile finn's parents go to see
sophie and realize she has a fever so
they decide to call the doctor
lena tells finn that she is very scared
about the monster and that she thinks
this might be their last night spent
together
so finn samira and lena decide to have a
threesome the next day finn and the
girls go to look for the lady to finish
the ritual
however when they get to her house a man
tells them that the lady and her son
left during the night and that they did
not plan to return
finn samira and lena decide to go to
school as usual there finn decides to
call his mom and tell her that he's fine
and also asks how sofi is to which his
mom replies that she's fine thanks to
the doctor who increased the dose of her
medicine
finn meets up with lena and samira when
they suddenly see a boy jump off a roof
they call an ambulance and both finn and
samir decide to get into the ambulance
with the boy
on the way to the hospital finn sees the
boy spit out a mushroom similar to the
one in his pills
meanwhile alina discovers that such
pills are sold by a new drug brand and
that there will be an event promoting it
lena decides to go to this event and
there she realizes these pills are being
promoted as if they were a solution to
make young people more sociable and
intelligent
she also realizes the director of the
company that sells the pills as finn's
father
meanwhile samira confesses to finn that
she is the doctor's daughter and that
she's also taking those pills
finn checks if she has any fungus in her
throat but he doesn't find anything
later finn and samira look at the
backpack of the boy who jumped off the
roof and they find some files about them
and sophie being adopted
at that moment the father of the boy who
was hospitalized arrives and tells finn
and samir that his son has just died
when he sees the teenagers have seen the
files he decides to tell them the truth
that everything is part of a ritual that
goes from generation to generation and
that makes them privileged meanwhile
lena sneaks into the company that sells
the pills and realizes that they have
corpses inside
and that's where they get the mushrooms
from
elena gets really scared so she rushes
out of there to tell samira and finn
what she just saw
finn visits his grandfather in the
hospital and when he arrives he realizes
that he's just died when he approaches
the corpse a doctor arrives and gives
him an injection in the neck
after a few hours finn wakes up at home
tied up
samir is there but she's also tied up
and suddenly the doctor appears and
tells him that the time has come
the doctor takes him to a room where he
sees his mom his dad sophie and others
dressed in tunics
he asks his twin for help but she tells
him that she already went through the
same thing
finn asks his father what all this is
about and he replies that he spent very
good years with him
but that it's time for him to give him
his body then the doctor takes finn to a
stretcher and we realize that the
grandfather's body is there
all the people in tunics tie finn's head
and cut his tongue a little
then they all sit and hold each other's
hands exhaling a strange smoke from
their mouths while their eyes go white
suddenly the grandfather revives and
takes off his clothes he approaches finn
and climbs on top of him exhaling that
same smoke through his mouth and in
defends
at that moment lena appears and hits the
grandfather and then she sprays the
other people with gasoline and sets them
a fire
after killing them all she unleashes
finn and they both run out of the house
when they leave samir is waiting for
them in the car so the three of them
leave in the vehicle quickly
however when they reach a bridge the
monster appears and causes the cars
brakes to fail
they collide with the side of the bridge
but the three of them manage to get out
before the car falls
the three teens decide to walk away and
just at that moment we see samir's eyes
also turn white
just like the ones who exhaled smoke
from their mouths
sweet to do she's already one of them
the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
recaps of the best horror series and
movies
thanks for watching